festival de cannes je pense que beaucoup
de gens savent que c'est la plus grande
réunion mondiale des gens de cinéma et
la plus grande concentration
quelque part vous comparez l'asile où
vous avez travaillé avec les autres vins
ce alors qu'il y avait un mélange des
malades de puisage parce que
heureusement quelques sites au tri
ban
oui 18 cents journalistes 400e et 35000
professionnel rené inverse êtes gentils
on a un sujet de lézat mercuzot ouais je
finis je fini de parler avec monsieur
durand c'est estivale de cannes a
toujours suscité
d'une part tout un grand que ce soit un
mouvement punk que ce soit un mouvement
violent
je ne refuse pas les sujets d'actualité
bien surtout quand ils sont traités j'ai
envie de me connaissent bien à vous
remercier on s'excuse ou bien des
personnes qui sont sur le plateau
d'avoir à faire tous les listes voilà
pour rester si vous voulez
ce moment ce n'était pas vide
c'est un moment important du festival de
tout ça prouve que le festival ne vit
pas chercher la police non